- [Instructor] Hello grammarians.
Today, we're gonna talk about
the confusion that happens
between these three homophones,
these three words that
sound exactly the same.
The preposition to, the
number two and the adverb too.
Now these words all sound very similar.
In fact, they sound exactly the same.
If I were to write this out phonetically,
here is what I would do.
That's how you'd write it
in the international phonetic alphabet
for every pronunciation.
You say that word, tu.
If you were looking
this up in a dictionary,
that's how you would render
this spelling phonetically.
That's the sound of those words.
They all sound exactly the same.
So what we need to do
is come up with a way
to keep them all separate.
And the way I'm going to do that
is with the prince of foods, the pizza.
Let's just call that a pizza.
Now, to, T-O, is a preposition
and so that means that it's expressing
some kind of relationship
in time and space.
In this case we can say,
one of its many, many meanings
is that it means it's
moving towards something.
So for example,
I am headed to Frank Cerisano's Pizzeria.
Right, so we can see in
context this is intentional,
it's in motion and that's why
we'd wanna use a preposition.
Where am I going?
To Frank Cerisano's Pizzeria.
Next, T-W-O, also pronounced
tu, you're welcome,
is a number.
It's this thing
so we'd use this mostly as an adjective
to describe how many things there are.
So I would say, at the pizzeria,
I ordered two pizzas
and ate them by myself.
Right, so when we're talking
about the number of things,
you wanna use T-W-O.
And finally we have T-O-O,
too, which is an adverb
and they can either mean
an over abundance of something or also.
Let me give you examples
for both of those cases.
So example case number
one, the excessive amount.
I ate too much pizza, I feel awful.
Now some of you may take issue with that
because you don't believe
that there is such a thing
as too much pizza, I understand.
So that's our excessive amount,
that's just mountains
and mountains of pizza
more than one person can
or should reasonably eat.
That's that definition.
And then there is the in
addition or also meaning
so my sister wanted pizza too,
but because of my greed,
she did not get any, sorry Julie.
Oh, I made her cry.
So in order to keep these three
very similar sounding words straight,
here's what you need to remember.
To, T-O, is a preposition
that means towards something.
I am headed to Frank Cerisano's Pizzeria.
T-W-O, the number two, is a number
so you'd say I ordered two pizzas.
Finally, T-O-O the adverb
means either there's an over
abundance, there's too much,
or in addition, my
sister wanted pizza too.
So grammarians, I say unto
you, remember the pizza.
You can learn anything.
David out.